welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Marvel
Studios werewolf by night the first MCU
special presentation from the studio
that doubles down on classic horror and
unleashes the beasts to the world Beyond
director composer Michael jokino crafted
this with Incredible production design
and details that are easy to overlook so
let's break this down shot by shot for
everything you might have missed spoiler
warning and let's get started we open on
a new Fanfare branding this as a Marvel
Studio special presentation
right
the music and Graphics are modeled
directly on the 1973 CBS special
presentation bumper
this is what a young Michael chiquino
likely would have seen on his TV as a
kid when the network would air an
exciting one-off special now Michael
jokino actually composed the Marvel
Fanfare music we have been hearing in
every title since 2016's doctor strange
and he composes this new music using the
same kind of Bongos from the 1973 CBS
bumper then we go into the main Marvel
Studios Fanfare but this gets disrupted
and turned black and white by a werewolf
slash
all right
jokino even sinks that slash so that it
occurs on his normal upswing of the horn
section
[Music]
and then after this music switches to a
more Sinister minor key version of the
music also of course that swipe is four
tears from four claws of werewolves
longer digits not three because that's
reserved for the slashes of another
Marvel heroes snakes Moon Knight was
added to the inner curvature of the r
where Bucky and Rocket previously were
because it's spooky male choir voices
chant followed by female choir voices
thank you
[Music]
can't really make out what they're
saying but it mirrors the partnership of
the male Jack with the female Elsa then
takino's opening title card of werewolf
by Knight uses the black and white
shadow and film stock quality and even
the Roman numeral copyright here from
titles like 1933's King Kong and 1941's
the Wolf Man two big influences on this
special then we start with the drawings
of the six OG Avengers the known
universe
with its Heroes and Marvels but what of
the darkness the narrator is Rick
Wasserman long time Marvel voice actor
who voices Thor in Avengers Earth's
Mightiest Heroes then we tilt down to
the depths Beneath The Avengers to an
illustration of a goblin creature it's
labeled figure xxvim which is not a
valid Roman numeral but the Latin
inscription translates to a winged
Monster by virtue and piety effectively
anonymously corrupted so is this really
a goblin or could it be a vampire beside
this creature are some daggers
presumably the weapons needed to kill it
and to the left a chart of lunar phases
presumably we are looking at a book or a
journal a guide kept by Ulysses
Bloodstone of creatures that he has
hunted over the years since the guy's
super old makes sense that it would be
in Latin this could be an ancient
grimoire like the Necronomicon the MCU
is now using this to show how all of our
monsters from folklore exist in this
universe living in the shadows then a
two-headed sea creature looks like a
mermaid and a merman and one slain by a
trident with the same kind of Serpentine
design as the dagger before then a
fork-tailed beast hunted with Arrows by
our man Ulysses Bloodstone his
creature's fur waving upward like Flames
so Ulysses Bloodstone is a Monster
Hunter for Marvel Comics first appearing
in 1975 but later in 2005 a couple
unnamed monster hunters from two comics
in 1960 for retcon to be the same guy as
Ulysses Ulysses was originally a caveman
kept alive for 10 000 Years From A Shard
of the alien blood gem fused into his
chest as the MCU did turning the
infinity gems into the Infinity Stones
so does this title making the blood gem
into the Bloodstone a powerful relic of
sorcery worn as a necklace and used to
weaken monsters and reveal their true
Natures could its Origins be connected
to the cosmic Infinity Stones or maybe
even with the vibranium that also
arrived to Earth via meteorite few more
theories on that at the end of the video
than a drawing of the actual Blood Stone
labeled lapis e sanguine which is Latin
for Bloodstone beneath that Latin
translating to Bloodstone family and
then either monsters or demons saving
Humanity or saving Humanity from
monsters and demons subtle syntax but it
is a major difference either way though
the Bloodstone family must have a bit of
evil or blood to fight these
then on the right we see
we see fit using the Bloodstone to repel
Bigfoot the caption reading Ulysses
Bloodstone fights a Sasquatch also known
as Bigfoot in British Columbia the lunar
phases that we saw before with the
Vampire Goblin thing are now surrounding
five historic monster hunters from
across cultures there's one in a suit of
armor then there's a warrior who looks
like he's from the Middle East then he
at least he's in the center who's
actually carrying the same ax that Joven
will later find in the Maze a hunter and
chainmail and then it looks like a
warrior from Ancient Asia there are five
of them in total just like the five
invited Hunters to tonight's ritual Elsa
made it six because they didn't expect
her to show on the left is a row of
weapons and then a chalice with what
reminds this baptized Catholic of Holy
Communion the Latin translates to Ritual
with the cup and the full moon to the
right a goat creature is impaled on a
stump maybe a sacrifice to initiate this
ritual so this may be depicting the
process of selecting a new Bloodstone
successor or coming together of all the
people who are part of this Society
notice that the lunar phases include
waxing and waning crescents and waxing
and waning gibbouses in a new moon but
no full moon is shown known as if these
ancestral Hunters knew never to conduct
this ritual on the night of a full moon
and the last illustration shows Ulysses
dead Fortis excretuti meaning strong and
free and then on the right his Epitaph
translates to Ulysses son of Septimus
Bloodstone was slain on the last full
moon of the year and at the end of the
Bloodshed so this tells that this
Ulysses Bloodstone was not an original
caveman he was part of a lineage of
Monster Hunters having a father named
Septimus but this also tells us that
Ulysses was killed on a full moon
interesting so did he die the hands of a
werewolf could it have been Jack himself
to initiate the succession ritual so
that he could infiltrate and free his
friend man thing but across dissolved
from the drawing of the moon to the
actual moon in the sky again this is not
a full moon yet as Jack will later say
he is five days until the next one Jack
arrives in this Bloodstone Temple the
door slowly rising from his feet and the
first thing we see is his Medallion
hanging from his hands as he walks down
this Hall you'll notice he suddenly
appears wearing it now meaning that this
is just a decorative thing that he wears
to blend in with the rest of the society
not really a badge that he's actually
proud proud of so Jack Russell in the
comics is werewolf by Knight born Jacob
rusoff a son of a Transylvanian with an
ancestral like athrope curse dating back
to Dracula's werewolf in the 18th
century a curse that was reawakened in
the 20th century by the darkhold jack
russell first appeared in Marvel
Spotlight 1972 And in the MCU who's
actually referenced in episode 2 of Moon
Knight wbn 0032 appearing on the bus
werewolf By Night number 32 being Moon
Knight's first comic appearance Gael
Garcia Bernal plays Jack making this the
second time for knowledge Aquino have
collaborated after Pixar's Coco for
which the Aquino could post a score and
Bernal voiced and sang the role of Uncle
Hector you'll notice Jack wears similar
face paint here as we saw decorating
many of the skulls in Coco reflecting
the tradition of the Mexican holiday of
Dia de los Muertos Jack goes into this a
bit later I uh I like your whole look
with the makeup some killer trademark
yeah
to honor my ancestors now the insurance
hallway is decorated with these murals
depicting more Monster slains and
various lat in phrases on
translating roughly to the end of life
consumed Spirit really it's a Latin
phrase used in relation to death meaning
to give up the ghost to the right of
that further down on the left wall the
center section
translating to the wild beasts flee the
dangers which they see and then at the
far end of the left wall only visible
later scenes Victoria out Moors bakare
odd regnum vivat Rex translating to
Victory or death call to Kingdom long
live the king but then on the wall to
Jack's right closest to him is omnis UNA
Manet Knox chunkare roughly translated
to one night waits to shorten further
down we know from the other later shots
it says
Latin puto not other putos this is
actually a quote from Roman playwright
Terence translating to I am a human
being I consider nothing human alien to
me and then at the far end on the right
wall closest to the door monstrum
notarez Mala Optima which I think means
a monster is nothing bad it's the best
so all together both sides of these wall
represent the argument that this story
is having with itself the left side
represents a more hostile mindset of Man
vs Beast of war and death the right side
is really the opposite of that argument
phrases begging for empathy seeing a
common Humanity in Monsters even a
werewolf wants you the shorter Knights
so that he can return to human form and
stop killing jokino said he was inspired
by movies like King Kong and wanted us
to see the deeper soul in the monsters
that we typically flee from and Hunt
that underneath the surface a lot of
these monsters are just humans that need
her help this Temple is filled with
mounted trophy heads of Ulysses beasts
including the ones depicted in the
opening illustrations paintings beside
each of them depicting their slains this
includes a painting for Ulysses his
confidence center with a rifle and a
sword crossed over it both of these
weapons will be used later on and in
this painting the Bloodstone is glowing
from his chest the music playing on a
record player in the background is
Irving Berlin's 1934 song I Never Had A
Chance a song playing in the hearts of
all these Hunters eager for a chance to
wield the Bloodstone next it's not
specifically to find what year this is
set in but shikino only really uses
songs from the 1930s and 1940s now
guarding this room are guards that look
like TVA Hunters but they don't seem to
be based on the context of this story
the other Hunters include barasso
azarell and leorn covering the shelves
of various objects throughout history
including a Roman helmet and a sphinx
statue Billy Swan notifies varusa that
Elsa has arrived and asperusa passes it
the Bloodstone now begins to glow red in
this black and white teacher note that
it did not glow red when we first saw it
on screen moments earlier it was only
Elsa's arrival that activated it so that
we now see its color Beyond this
monotone filter like it was always read
to these characters but now to the
viewer the stone has only come alive
when its rightful possessor has come
near this whole concept of Technicolor
red in black and white film was famously
used by Steven Spielberg and Schindler's
List and more recently in the MCU the
blinking red light on the Stark toaster
in the commercial in one division
episode 1 this use of color is designed
to draw our attention to punctuated
violence in an otherwise numbing or
desensitize Mison sin and as in one
division this is an indicator that a
Technicolor meta reality will soon be
revealed Jack meets the hunter Joven I
can almost smell the blood in your hands
yeah little nod to Jack having a bit of
heightened smell incenses that of a
canine Jovan is actually played by Kirk
Thatcher and this isn't his first MCU
appearance this guy started as an ilm
creature designer who played the Boombox
punk in Star Trek for the Voyage Home
and it reprized a similar guy in
Spider-Man homecoming now that guy was a
New Yorker Joven sounds like a Scotsman
probably not the same character Joven
was the one of these Hunters to greet
Jack warmly but he's also the first to
try to kill him in the Maze revealing
this Warmness is actually part of his
deception game jack points to the goblin
vampire monster head but him
I fought a few times hmm he's never
looked so alive and again this was the
first Monster we saw in the opening
illustrations and the fact that this
monster was transformed by being
corrupted makes it interesting that he
has a history with Jack Russell who
transforms into a werewolf instead of
being a monster full time Bruce agreets
Elsa Bloodstone at the door Elsa
Bloodstone being the daughter of Ulysses
Bloodstone in the comics and a recurring
badass monster hunter in recent Comics
at one point she does team up with the
midnight Sons but Versa challenges her
what aspect of Bloodstone are we after
exactly the strength it lends the
protection
longevity so what I do with it after
I've earned it will be none of your
business yeah it really seems like Elsa
doesn't want the Bloodstone for its
powers but really just to keep verusa
from passing it on to someone less
worthy barusa goes around announcing
their kill numbers 26 Progresso 37 for
Azrael 43 for leorne 57 for Joven and
over a hundred for Jack this tells us
that at some point Jack managed to
coordinate his monthly werewolf
transformations to position himself to
slay monsters when he was in werewolf
form and assuming they'd only be able to
coordinate one target per full moon and
there's 12 full moons in a year that
means that he's been a werewolf doubling
as a fellow Monster Hunter for around
nine years now all of these characters
wear the same Medallion that mark them
as part of this Bloodstone Society
except Elsa who is no Medallion since
she parted ways with it it's also
interesting that we never hear what
else's kill number is they all assume
she's inexperienced but in reality her
kill number could be a lot higher and I
love how Elsa interrupts verusa by
dragging the chair across the room much
like the irreverent But ultimately most
qualified Agent J in Men In Black
foreign the back side of Ulysses coffin
reads this end up and when Billy inserts
the crank a little puff of dust blows
out based on Ulysses State of Decay how
long has this guy really been dead is
this really his corpse or could it be an
animatronic replica that he had made
before he died whatever this Ulysses
spot is lays out the rules a monster has
been released to the ground and whoever
kills it first will claim the Bloodstone
he signs off with good luck
I'll be
rotting for you oh brother this guy
stinks get exactly the kind of cheesy
pun the Crypt Keeper would make entails
from the Crypt grusa says that no
weapons will be allowed other than some
that have been scattered around the maze
it sounds like all these weapons will be
ones formerly owned by Ulysses making
the squad also feel a lot like the movie
clue a bunch of eccentric characters
gathered to this house each having
access to a set amount of weapons Russo
lays out the stakes there is only one
Bloodstone
and it can have only one keeper I love
how the bloodstone's red light forms a
lens flare across the camera pretty much
every time it's shown almost as if its
redness is eager to jump off the screen
to break this reality Bruce also warns
that not all of them will survive those
who do not survive
will be honored
appropriately
for tonight
it is every Hunter for themselves
[Music]
victims will be herself and recalling
Hitchcock's final shot of psycho that
superimposed over Norman bates's face
the skull of his mother werewolf by
night is a ton of fun but thankfully
there's an easier way to enjoy the perks
of werewolfiness without you know being
one magic the Gathering Arena not only
brings the vast scope of the deck
building card collecting classic to your
phone it's also got werewolves Magic the
Gathering is celebrated its 30th
anniversary and it's bigger than ever in
MCG Arena you can learn to play collect
cards challenge your friends and build
Decks that show off your favorite fandom
no matter what you're into you'll find
it in MTG Arena which has tons of
different themed planes based on horror
sci-fi fantasy and more for werewolves
you'll want to visit the plane of
innistrad with the day to night mechanic
you can transform and Unleash the Power
of your werewolves under the full moon
and take on Legions of witches zombies
vampires and ghosts MTG arena is a great
entry point to get into or get back into
magic all you have to do is download the
game on mobile tablet or desktop to play
and if you're looking for a help in hand
you can learn to play or catch up on all
things MTG Arena on their official
YouTube channel to get started with
magic the Gathering Arena just click the
link in the description below download
MTG arena for free and begin assembling
your werewolf deck today Jack draws the
title meaning that he will enter the
maze first led by a flaming tuba player
who according to the credits is actor
David Silverman which is also the name
of the actor who played Jen Walters
potential employer in She-Hulk episode 2
but it is a fairly common name could
just be for guys I just love this tuba
torch it's very Mad Max Fury Road and I
love how it functions both as a torch to
light the way but also an announcement
of every new maze entry and let's be
honest a completely foreboding sound of
Doom has the rest of them chant we
spilled the blood for the hunt for stone
and Creed for those who forged our own
blade to rid this land of its
Abominations there is no peace without
blood and so it shall be and I have to
address this those who forged our own
blade obviously part of this monster
hunting tradition in the MCU is gonna
involve our man blade but jokino said
that behind the scenes they discuss
should they bring in Blade and decide to
ultimately know that he doesn't need to
be part of this story as Jack makes his
way into the maze we see it from a high
angle and if you look closely you can
see man thing's Shadow lumbering around
the background in the upper right this
plot structure of hunters forced into a
maze to search for a monster of course
based on the Greek myth of the Minotaur
in The Labyrinth the Minotaur was
eventually slain by the great hero
Theseus but this story's plot subverts
that with this awesome twist the monster
is not one that we have to slay the
monster is a damsel in distress whom we
must save interesting note that the
English language uses May's Labyrinth
synonymously but historically Maize
refers to a puzzle with multiple choices
of paths whereas the Labyrinth is meant
to be a unicural path a singular path to
the center so in that sense the
Labyrinth has come to symbolize
something more Elemental a destined
Journey that we all must go on a spiral
that goes deeper and deeper into our own
subconscious as we must face our own
inner fears now Jack initially wanders
the maze in this 42nd unbroken shot and
he nearly finds man thing he actually
approaches a hedge wall where Ted is
actually hiding but he turns away when
the tuba blows for the second Hunter
[Music]
yeah they definitely would have made
contact there if that next Hunter didn't
arrive right then Elsa finds a
phonograph which now plays 1939's
wishing will make it so written by BG Da
Silva sung by Vera Lynn since this is
kind of a Wizard of Oz dream quest for
Elsa this challenge is largely a matter
of this heroine wishing there's no home
like the Bloodstone but Joven attacks
gas is coming for you Aussie get up in
the right corner there was a q Mark Q
marks appear on film frames to cue the
projectionists to switch over to the
next reel in this special Q marks sync
with the structure of the ax here we are
switching into Act 2 with the hunters in
the Maze and Elsa and Jackie didn't know
each other another q Mark will appear at
the end of the second act when verusa
catches Jack signaling the shift in act
3 where they go back into the temple
Elsa follows a steamy footprint and a
steamy handprint on the wall toward the
central Mausoleum where liorn is hiding
meaning man thing must have chased liorn
into the mausoleum and Lyon must have
been afraid of man being because that
acid only excretes when the victim feels
fear after Elsa cuts off Leonard's arm
she instinctively kicks it away knowing
that it's still a usable weapon arguably
even more dangerous now that it's
severed because you know you can tote it
around and during the fight between
these two shikuno scores it with the
psycho strings
[Music]
the thing I love about good horror
action is how a body postmortem can
create a new burden whether it's a
zombie resurrecting or a xenomorphous
acid blood burning through everything or
in this case Elsa having to cover
Leonard's mouth a mouth that has been
wedged open by her arrow in order to
keep Joven from hearing them Solutions
creating new problems Jack returns to
the Hedge wall with man thing where a
classic Jurassic Park style jump scare
turns into a delightful twist
yes this is man thing man thing is Dr
Ted Salas in the comics from a team
trying to recreate the super soldier
serum in the Florida Everglades but he
gets pursued by aim and injects himself
with the test serum and crashes his car
into the swamp where Mystic forces from
an interdimensional Rift leading to the
Nexus of all realities transformed Ted
into a plant matter humanoid who senses
emotion he gets enraged by fear and
burns those who feel fear and touch him
due to him secreting a kind of acid yes
the Nexus of all realities is a big part
of man think comic so yeah this guy is a
bean spawned from the Multiverse the
creature design here is pretty great
it's a comic accurate mix of vines and
Moss and fungi and Roots but with just
enough Humanity in his eyes so that we
love him man thing is performed by
Carrie Jones part of the effects team of
this and a number of titles over the
years and recently played Black
cursedanta in the book of Boba Fett
additional vocalizations were done by
long time Marvel editor Jeffrey Ford
Jack says well you could say that you're
going to be careful each time and here
we go again you can't counting on me to
save you this is the last time yeah it
makes us wonder what trouble or capture
Ted gotten before like maybe he was
captured by blade or groups like stake
or the mi-13 or by the dodc Jack locks
himself in with Elsa and in this room
are a number of sarcophagi with names
that might connect to crew or friends of
production see Jacob Howard McDougall or
July 1861 died March 1907. there's
actually a Marvel VFX assistant
coordinator named Samantha McDougall
then there's another one born June 1884
died not too long later September 1892
and then there's another one Brian
something born August 1842 died December
1939. David long born June 12 1882 died
February 28 1961 David long is actually
a prop maker on this title this guy
probably constructed this himself then
Mika Brandon and kleila born May 5th
1885 died February 28 1961 Brandon
kleila is an art director and former
Disney imagineer who's actually a friend
of Michael giacino and then Jorge
dewalos ralphones born July 17 1880 died
February 28 1961. interestingly these
past three all died on the same day okay
February 28 1961 it was probably the
same thing that killed all three of them
Annabelle Andrea Graciela born 1922 died
in 1968. Griffith Berkey one donski born
January 4th 1935 died September 17 1966.
Beverly something important September 7
1932 died November 12 1986 and 1986
suggests that despite the 1930s
Aesthetics of all this this is likely
taking place in the present day and then
of course Elsa's Aunt Francis Brisbane
Bloodstone born 1873 died in 1922. so
they still talk about family but all
families have something in common they
follow us for good and for bad they
stay like they become an atmosphere both
of these Hunters inherited their Natures
from their fathers in Elsa's case this
following her like an atmosphere
explains why we are seeing this in black
and white black and white was how her
father Ulysses saw the world black and
white good versus evil man vs Monster
and this narrow view still shapes Elsa's
literal atmosphere until her perspective
finally changes in the final scene Elsa
smashes open francis's coffin she was
positive that she'd come back from the
dead at some point sounds like on
Francis believed in a zombie uprising
maybe setting the stage for Marvel
Zombies in the MCU Jack advises about
man thing when you run into him just
just treat him like an old friend
call him by his name which is Ted yeah
notice how Joven doesn't call him by his
name tell him he
was drove and feels the fear man thing
secretes his toxin that fries joven's
head but else is able to connect with
the monster
Ted
and man thinks eyes go from spread out
ink plots to more condensed irises
helping us connect with him emotionally
Jack blows the wall man thing runs out
and Elsa uses the clamp to snag the
Bloodstone from his shoulder but Jack
touches it and it burns him since this
stone is an analog for the ruby slippers
it's similar to how those slippers
initially burned the undeserving in The
Wizard of Oz later on Jack apologizes
for not telling Elsa I'm an idiot I know
but I'm also a human
perhaps not in the category that you
would call a human a human yeah he
scratches himself his canine instinct's
coming out well check realizes that
barusa is going to use that Bloodstone
to turn him prematurely he looks around
the temple at each of the heads in the
wall at first it seems like he's just
worried he's gonna be the next mounted
head on that wall but actually he is
registering dark parts of the room where
he can later perch to hide and actually
the final winged Beast that he looks at
is exactly where he hides later he warns
Elsa not to break eye contact which of
course is how canines communicate
dominance and he smells her body
I need to remember you
and does it work
once so who was that lucky partner Jack
has had romantic Partners in the comics
a girlfriend named Roxanna an affair
with morbius living vampires ex Martine
Bancroft but I am wondering if his
forever person could be Ted I'm just
saying we could all be so lucky to find
ourselves a fungal humanoid who brings
us coffee in the morning barusa uses the
Bloodstone to transform Jack and as he
changes jakino uses another long take
but keeps the camera on Elsa just to
convey her fear and her unwillingness to
break eye contact Jack's transformation
is actually shown in the shadow on the
wall behind her jackino says this is all
done in camera no VFX meaning that in
order to pull that off they must have
had to time the strobe light to swap in
one stand-in for another in the costume
that would show the fur as a shadow and
they probably pulled that off by putting
that second actor closer to the light
source so that he would appear larger on
the wall and when the Bloodstone
finishes changing him it releases a
little Shockwave
[Music]
oven it's like a little burp from the
sentient saying that's enough but Jack
escapes
who clears the hunters search the room
looking for the werewolf until the
camera tilts up and we see him hiding in
playing
revealing his position only by his eyes
suddenly glowing
hereditary when the character is
crouched in the dark corner of the
ceiling in plain sight and it takes us
over a minute to even see her jokino
gives us this master reveal shot of the
werewolf light flickering on his face
but his eyes continuing to glow and they
use practical prosthetics for this
character evoking The Wolf Man in the
movie Monsters of that era but I love
how his ancestral face paint remains on
his skin takino also uses a dolly Zuma
pectir a famous shot in horror and in
this case making it look like the
werewolf is floating toward us kind of
like Dracula in those classic films Jack
bites barasso's ear and then Elsa helps
out grabbing her father's sword and then
knocking brasso's neck against it
actually level you can see Billy peeking
out from behind the casket reacting to
all this in shot jakino uses a pretty
impressive long take now that actually
starts in the main room and then follows
the guard as Jack throws him across the
screen into the entrance hallway and we
stay in this fight Jack rips open a guy
so that his blood spills in the camera
and oozes down with the same exact speed
as the gradually closing gate in the
background such great shot composition
here and at several points notice how
Jack could Escape but he clearly chooses
not to as bloodthirst has overtaken this
werewolf he will not finish this level
until he gets 100 clearance rate
meanwhile Elsa uses her father's sword
to slay azero probably the most brutal
live-action kill we have seen in the MCU
to date and after she pulls verusa away
from him jack pins Elsa but she never
breaks eye contact and caresses his face
showing empathy for the monster and he
flees into the night but varusa lifts
Ulysses rifle to shoot Elsa but man
thing drops in and kills her tossing her
crispy course and he loses coffin making
this coffin flop a corn cop TV outtake I
didn't read [ __ ] actually asked the
producer on this title Brian Gay about
the relative depictions of violence and
all this I found it interesting no guns
are really fired aside to win varusa
nearly fires it but that's when man
thing gets her do you see that as the
distinction gun violence versus more old
school fantasy Weaponry well we wanted
to set the idea that this monster
hunting culture is steeped in lore right
like and these people have been doing it
forever they don't they don't just they
didn't start yesterday it's been
centuries it's been eons and so we
thought it was more fun that they would
be skilled and talented with sort of um
more you know medieval or older style
weapons or things like that I will say
that I much prefer watching a sword
fight than a gunfight I think it's more
visceral and specifically in the close
quarters of the mace the Bloodstone
turns Elsa back into color revealing her
jacket to be red suggesting that she
said she heard the famous Judy Garland
Over The Rainbow from The Wizard of Oz
painting Elsa as the Dorothy of this
story the girl who defeated the wicked
witch to keep the Ruby treasure that
always belonged to her ironically
whereas Dorothy's homecoming was a
transition from Technicolor back to
sepia this is the opposite Elsa's
nightmare was black and white and her
Awakening takes her back into color
actually chatted with actress Laura
Donnelly about the deeper meaning of
this color shift whether it's something
Elsa experiences in her point of view as
well I wanted to ask you about that
color shift at the end of this set to
Over the Rainbow I love this moment you
know it's a shift in color for the
viewer but it also feels like an
emotional moment for Elsa I want to ask
you how you think Elsa sees it was her
world always in color until that moment
and now we are finally seeing it the way
she does or do you think she might have
been living in a black and white World
until that moment I think that there is
definitely a psychological aspect to
that black and white turned into color
and I think for Elsa something has
clicked in so I think it is a bit more
like she has been in that black and
white or that uh you know that shaded
kind of world and now she feels like she
has come home but in a more genuine way
than when she first walked through the
door of her family home one cannot help
but draw a line between this Scarlet
colored reality warp and what we saw
from one to maximoff's chaos magic in
one division especially when that magic
initially created a black and white hex
reality and then later between episodes
two and three that reality shifted from
black and white to color this tint of
sorcery all seems to have similar
effects in the MCU and it could be that
the Bloodstone the reality Stone the
dark hold and Wanda could all be
different Wells tapping into the same
current of chaos magic that courses
through reality in the MCU we see that
this music is playing from the record
player in manthing and Jack's Camp
meaning man thing must have placed that
record in stylus with his plant fingers
I love it and he here now in color you
actually see that Ted has a splash of
color himself the sweet yellow flower on
his shoulder like he's wearing a
boutonniere a flower that matches the
yellow flower on the mug that he hands
Jack I'm telling you these two are the
most adorable couple clearly they have
some history and these two have seen
each other at their worst and they share
an affection that keeps them from
attacking each other empathy for
Monsters wins out and as Judy Garland's
voice hits that final note jokino closes
with the end in the same cursive font as
a final shot of The Wizard of Oz and as
we do at the end of that film we now
wonder was this all a dream did anything
we just saw have any bearing on the
reality that we know in this case the
canonicity of the MCU of course it will
Elsa Bloodstone werewolf by night man
thing all of these guys can return in
titles like blade Act of the coven of
chaos and someday the midnight Suns
because now we know it's not just people
who need saving in the MCU it's the
monsters as well you can follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at avos
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you